six one seven eight three zero 4750 is
the number let's see who is next why
don't we try the six five zero area code
caller from six five zero who's this
what's on your mind so I've been
watching hello yes who's this this is
Aaron again so I remember watching your
video on how's about shooting sorry the
video on which which shooting was that
the Thousand Oaks one the one in
California yes yes okay
yeah so one thing I noticed when you're
talking about dentistry you don't you
don't know how they work I'm sorry you
noticed that when I talked about
gun-free zones I didn't know how they
worked yeah so basically the only people
who can carry firearms are not security
guards about off-duty officers were at
the bar only on-call active duty police
officers so what happened at the bar is
there's a security guy with the
concealed carry permit in at California
which is incredibly difficult to get all
in mind that so he's thrown he's been
thoroughly vetted so he was an austerity
of gun and he said had to rely on trying
to grab his gun he got shot killed and
there was a lot of obstacle cops at the
place so one of them could have been a
designated driver or a couple of them
and they could have had their guns
so essentially gun-free zone got those
people killed or got people killed
because there's two lines of defense no
spit from being able to shoot back let
me see if I understand what you're
saying
I want to make sure I'm not mistaking it
you're saying I don't understand
gun-free zones and that as a result of
the way that the gun-free zone works in
Thousand Oaks California
all of the people that were there that
were reported to have firearms weren't
enough people to stop the bad guy with
the gun and that more people with guns
would have been there if it were not a
gun-free zone is that what you're saying
I'm saying that the security guys was
not allowed to have his gun because it
does freeze oh okay right so he took the
gun from the shooter is that what was I
right on that no no he was not he was so
the security guard instead of having to
take out his gun and shooting the guy
dead he happens
rustle and try to grab the gun from the
guy he got killed he got killed by
police what which I don't even know if
we're talking about the same incident at
this point Thousand Oaks the one where
the guy came into a bar and shot and
killed a bunch of people right the
security guard had a gun or he had a
concealed carry permit but he didn't
have it done on them because it's a
gun-free zone okay I correct me if I'm
misremembering the story and I'm just
going from memory because there's been
so many shootings is that not the one
where when police arrived the security
guard had the actual shooter pinned with
his knee and the guy's back and his gun
on his back is that is are we talking
about that story that was Chicago that's
a completely different one oh okay I'm
sorry then I'm just mixing up the
details I'm sorry I apologize okay yes
of a Thousand Oaks shooter
he walked to a bar they had the security
guard who ever could still carry permit
but he was not allowed to have a gun
because it's gun free zone got it so the
better solution for a problem like
always serve alcohol so we don't want
people with drunk the firearms is the
one where they have in Minnesota is
Michigan a Minnesota if I remember
correctly where if you have a drop of
alcohol in your system you better get
arrested for the DUI or like a public
intoxication looking at lose your
license that that's a much smarter
system because again the gun-free zone
California prevented two different lines
of defense from having two firearms
potentially having a fire on top okay
but so big picture your view is that
just more more guns in bars would
prevent shootings is that generally what
you're saying it's a bit of a strong man
but my line of talking I'm saying that
if you drink and you have a gun on you
she's going to jail okay that's fine but
do you want more guns in bars yes you do
okay all right very good appreciate the
call